SENATE COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS
OF CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS.
SO WE HAVE A SIMILAR WIENER IS
HERE A SAUCE THERE'S CENTER
WHERE I COULD MISS UNDER WIENER.
AND WE HAVE. WE'RE NEED A
MEMBERS. WE ARE WAY TO LISA
.
GOOD MORNING WELCOME TO
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE WE ARE
GOING TO START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE AND WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH A SENATOR UMBERG'S
BILL SIR NUMBER PLEASE BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
CENTER LEYVA. BEFORE THE DAY IS
SB SIX NINE SIX IT'S UP PURPOSE
IS TO PREVENT VOTERS FROM BEING
MISLED PARTICULARLY WITH
RESPECT TO THE PARTY
DESIGNATION AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT PARTY IN CALIFORNIA
TODAY THE SECOND LARGEST GROUP
VOTERS ARE INDIVIDUALS
REGISTERED AS NO PARTY
PREFERENCE THIS GROUP IS MORE
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS
INDEPENDENT VOTERS. THIS GROUP
IS TWENTY EIGHT POINT 6% OF
CALIFORNIA VOTING ELECTED IS
THE FASTEST GROWING. ELECTED OF
ANY OF THE MAJOR CATEGORIES
BACK TO MY OWN COUNTY AS WELL
AS IN THE STATE. DECLINED WELL
IN THE STATE CLIMB THE STATE
VOTERS OR NO PARTY PREFERENCE
VOTERS ARE NUMBER TWO AND FOR
EXAMPLE ORANGE COUNTY THEIR
THEIR QUICKLY RISING TO NUMBER
TWO. IN ORDER TO REDUCE VOTER
CONFUSION ESPECIALLY AMONG
THOSE VOTERS WHO WISH TO
REGISTER WITHOUT ANY PARTY
PREFERENCE AND STAY
INDEPENDENT. SB SIX NINE SIX
WILL PROHIBIT THE NAME OF A
POLITICAL PARTY FROM INCLUDING
THE WORD INDEPENDENT DECLINE TO
STATE OR NO PARTY PREFERENCE OR
ANY VARIATION OF THOSE WORDS.
UNDER EXISTING LAWS PROHIBITED
FOR THE NAME OF A NEW PARTY TO
BE SIMILAR TO THE NAME OF
EXISTING PARTY. SO AS TO AVOID
MISLEAD VOTERS MEANING
DEMOCRATS REPUBLICANS
LIBERTARIANS ALL HAVE
PROTECTIONS ON THEIR NAME
UNFORTUNATELY THIS PROTECTION
DOES NOT EXTENDED AND VOTERS
CURRENTLY IS A WYOMING BANDS
WORD INDEPENDENT AND OF ANY NEW
POLITICAL PARTY JUST TO AVOID
THE- KIND OF CONFUSION THAT
WE'RE ADDRESSING HERE. THE
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY HAS
OVER A HALF MILLION REGISTERED
VOTERS. ALL OF THE OTHER
CALIFORNIA MINOR PARTIES
COMBINED. THE CHAIR OF THE
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY MARK
SEIDENBERG KNOWLEDGE THAT
VOTERS ARE BEING CONFUSED BY
SAYING A LOT OF PEOPLE JUST
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY'RE
DOING WHEN THEY FILL OUT A FORM
MR SEIDENBERG WENT ON TO SAY
THAT ONE REASON THE AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT PARTY DOES NOT WANT
TO CHANGE ITS NAME IS THAT THE
PARTY WOULD BE FORCED TO GET
NEW VOTERS AND THAT'S
EXPENSIVE. AND IT WOULD HAVE TO
GET NEW WORDS PRESUMABLY
BECAUSE- VOTERS WHO ACTUALLY
UNDERSTAND THAT THE AMERICAN
PAN PARTY IS NOT. REALLY A
PARTY OF INDEPENDENCE WOULD
LEAVE THAT PARTY IN RE REGISTER
PERHAPS IS NO PARTY PREFERENCE.
OUT WITH ME HERE IS MISTER
MITCHELL. AS WITNESS AND WITH
THAT MADAM CHAIRMAN TURN OVER
TO MISTER MITCHELL. THANK YOU
YOUR WITNESS AND SUPPORT PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HOW MUCH WITH POLITICAL DATA.
AND I'D LIKE TO THINK THE
SENATOR AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR TIME AND ATTENTION THIS
BILL THERE'S ALREADY A- A GREAT
WRITTEN ANALYSIS AND I THINK
THE COMMITTEE. STAFF AND
MEMBERS UNDERSTAND THE ISSUE
VERY WELL. I'LL JUST ADD A
COUPLE POINTS WITH HALF A
MILLION REGISTRANTS WE'RE
TALKING ONE IN FORTY CALIFORNIA
VOTERS. THE THAT WE BELIEVE
THEY ARE IN MISTAKENLY. AND
THIS USED TO BE BASED ON
ANECDOTES AND NOW IT'S BASED ON
REAL DATA SO WE HAVE BOTH THE
LA TIMES POLL. SAMPLING WE DONE
WITH CAPITAL WEEKLY IN A LOT OF
DATA TO SHOW THAT WHEN ASKED
BETWEEN 324% OF AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT VOTERS. CAN EVEN
IDENTIFY THE POLITICAL PARTY.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK THIS
IS ROOTED IN KIND OF IGNORANCE
OR PEOPLE JUST NOT
UNDERSTANDING OR THEY SHOULD
KNOW BETTER BUT THE REALITY IS
THAT WE'VE FOUND. VERY
PROMINENT PEOPLE REGISTERED
WITH AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY
THE- THE FATHER OF A STATE
SENATOR. THE WIFE OF AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. A SENIOR
MEMBER OF THE GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION A SENIOR MEMBER
OF THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE ADMINISTRATION. AND THEN
EVEN WITH THIS NEW
REDISTRICTING COMMISSION. WE'VE
HAD. TWENTY THOUSAND APPLICANTS
AND A NUMBER OF THEM OF PUT
THAT THEY ARE AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT. AND WE HAVE FOUND
JUST IN OUR FIRST LOOK AT
MATCHING THESE VOTERS THAT
THEIR SEVENTY FIVE OF THEM.
THAT SAID THAT THEY WERE
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT ON THE
FORM THINKING THEY'RE
INDEPENDENT THAT'S WHAT IT
MEANS. THERE REALLY REGISTERED
NO PARTY PREFERENCE. ANOTHER
TWELVE SEVEN WERE. PUTTING NO
PARTY PREFERENCES THEY'RE
READY. TO FORM AND THEY ARE
INCORRECTLY REGISTERED AS
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT. SO
THERE'S A BIG CONFUSION AND I
HOPE THAT THIS BILL WILL HELP
ALLEVIATE THAT THANK YOU. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING. PARKS
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GIVE ME MARK WHEN WE
HAVE IT SECRETARY STATE ALEX
PADILLA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THIRTY ONE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. COME ON UP SIR YOU MAY
SIT AT THE TABLE. IT RIGHT
THERE. PUBLIC I'LL MOVE OVER TO.
ALL RIGHT TO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH PLEASE. HOW MANY
DID THE OTHER PEOPLE GET I HE
WAS LESS THAN TWO MINUTES OKAY
THANK YOU YOU'RE WELCOME. YEAH.
OKAY YOU CAN ALWAYS COME IN
UNDER WE LOVE THAT OKAY PLEASE
PROCEED SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON
GOOD MORNING EXCUSE ME MY NAME
IS MARK SEIDENBERG I'M VICE
CHAIRMAN OF THE AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT PARTY CALIFORNIA.
AND THE STATE WITH THEM MR ON
BURKE MADE ABOUT BY STATE WAS
OUT OF CONTEXT SO I WANT TO
START OFF WITH THAT. OKAY FIRST
OF ALL THE AMERICAN INTO THE
PARTY HAS BEEN AROUND SINCE
JULY EIGHTH NINETEEN. SIXTY
SEVEN. WE'VE BEEN QUALIFIED
POLITICAL PARTY SINCE. NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT WE ARE CANDIDATES
OF WALLACE WHEN THEY CAME IN
FIRST A THIRD. IN SOME COUNTIES
WE HAD ACCESS 220% OF VOTERS
VOTED FOR A PARTY. SAM YORTY
BEFORE MERYL LOS ANGELES VOTER
FOR WELL WALL SOON ONE MAY
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT SO WE HAD
STRONG SUPPORT. OUR PARTY IS
NOT ABOUT TO CHANGE ITS NAME SO.
ONE ISSUE IS THAT THEY SAY THAT
THE WE HAVE TO HAVE. A
CONVENTION TO CHANGE OUR NAME
STATE LAW PROHIBITS PRECLUDES
US FROM HAVING A CONVENTION
UNTIL AFTER THE DIRECT PRIMARY.
AND WE HAVE TELL CONVENTION IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY INTERSTATE
CHAIRMAN HAS TO CALL CONVENTION
AND- HI SECURE TERM IS
CURRENTLY IN THE HOSPITAL.
OUTSIDE THE COUNTY SO COULD NOT
WE COULD EVEN CALL CONVENTION.
SO THIS IS STILL A RUSE. ANYWAY
BOTTOM LINE IS OUR PARTY IS NOT
ABOUT CHANGE ITS NAME AND I
KNOW SURRENDER MY TIME TO THE
NEXT BAKER. THANK YOU SIR NEXT
WITNESS IN SUPPORT RICHARD
WINGER BALLOT ACCESS NEWS I
HAVE FOUR POINTS. THE FIRST IS
GIVEN THE TIMING IN THIS BILL
IT VIOLATES DUE PROCESS THE
SECOND POINT IS THE LAW THE
BILL IS VAGUE. IT DOESN'T
CLEARLY SPECIFY WHICH WORDS ARE
PROHIBITED. THE THIRD IS. THERE
ARE MANY. OKAY I'VE I'VE ASKED
FOR A THE SERGEANT AT ARMS TO
PUT A PIECE OF PAPER IN FRONT
OF YOU. THIS SHOWS THAT FORTY
SEVEN OF THE FIFTY STATES AT
ONE TIME OR ANOTHER. IT HAD A
PARTY OF QUALIFIED PARTY WITH
THE WORD EITHER INDEPENDENT OR
INDEPENDENCE. SOME GROUPS WANT
CALIFORNIA TO SECEDE FROM THE
UNITED STATES. THIS BILL I
ASSUME IT BANS THE WORD
INDEPENDENCE ENOUGH I'M WRONG I
HOPE THE AUTHOR WILL CORRECT
ME. IT WOULD BE IMPOSSIBLE FOR
SUCH A PARTY O DESCRIBE ITS
MISSION IF THE WORD
INDEPENDENCE. IS NOT PERMITTED.
AND THE FOURTH IS THIS BILL
VIOLATES. THE FIRST AMENDMENT
OF ALMOST IDENTICAL LAW WAS
DECLARED UNCONSTITUTIONAL IN
TENNESSEE I WILL GIVE YOU THE
SITES IF YOU WANT BUT THE TIME
IS TICKING AND THERE ARE FAR
BETTER WAYS TO FIX THE PROBLEM.
IT'S MUCH KINDER TO MAKE THINGS
LIKE THIS VOLUNTARY TWELVE
STATES LET PARTY'S CHANGE THEIR
NAME. EVEN THE TWO MAJOR
PARTIES HAVE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF
THAT MINNESOTA THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY CHANGED ITS NAME TO
DEMOCRATIC FARMER LABOR. THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR CHANGED ITS NAME
TO THE INDEPENDENT REPUBLICAN
PARTY SALAS SWITCHED BACK.
FIFTEEN YEARS LATER. WE SHOULD
LET ANY PARTY CHANGED ITS NAME
JUST AS OREGON DOES DOES THE SO
WHY DOES. IF YOU DON'T FORCE
THEM TO CHANGE THEIR NAME THEY
MIGHT. FREE LEE COME UP WITH A
NAME THEY LIKE. AND FINALLY
IT'S SO SIMPLE TO JUST HAVE A
CHOICE ON THE VOTER
REGISTRATION CARD THAT SAYS I
AM AN INDEPENDENT VOTER. WHY
THIS IS NEVER BEEN DONE I DON'T
UNDERSTAND. THANK YOU SIR
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS UNDER
STERN. OKAY VERY GOOD WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR UMBERG
THANK YOU. CENTERS LEYVA AND
STERN I DON'T THERE'S ANY
QUESTION THAT VOTERS ARE BEING
MISLED BY THE TERM INDEPENDENT
THE AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY
I THINK IT IS A GOOD SUGGESTIN
AMERICAN INDEPENDENT PARTY
VOLUNTARILY CHANGED ITS NAME TO
SOMETHING ELSE THE THAT THEY
MIGHT LIKE OTHER THAN NO PARTY
PREFERENCE OR DECLINE THE STATE
OR ANOTHER. TERM THAT CONTAINS
THE WORD INDEPENDENT THIS IS A-
A MEASURE THAT SIMPLY MAKE SURE
THAT VOTERS AREN'T MISLED WHEN
THE RED STRING AND IN THE
PROBLEM WHEN THEY MISS REGISTER
IS THAT FOR EXAMPLE THE CAN'T
VOTE IN CERTAIN PRIMARIES SO IN
THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION WHICH
IS COMING UP AND TWENTY. TWENTY
IF YOUR REGISTERS AMERICAN
INDEPENDENT YOU CAN'T VOTE IN
THE AT AND CERTAIN PRIMARIES
AND SO A NUMBER OF VOTERS ARE
MISLED THE ATTEMPT TO VOTE THAT
CAN'T DO SO THE SIMS ASSEMBLY
ACTS TO RECTIFY THAT ISSUE
VIRGIN AYE VOTE. THANK NUMBER
BEFORE WE TAKE THE VOTE LET'S
CALL THE ROLL. NUMBER NUMBER
HERE NIELSEN HERTZBERG. A ONE
YEAR LABOR HERE STERN STERN
HERE. THANK YOU DO WE HAVE A
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SANDOR STERN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MOTION IS THAT THE
ASSEMBLY MOMENTS HE CONQUERED
IN NUMBER. HI NUMBER I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN. I HEARD ABOUT. IT IN
THE THIS IS ON THE AMERICAN
DENTAL PARKING. SHE'S JUST CALL.
NIELSEN NIELSEN NO NIELSEN NO
HERTZBERG LEYVA LEYVA AYE STERN
STERN NINE. ALL RIGHT. WEST
MATTER IS. SB TWO SIX EIGHT BY
SENATOR WIENER. SIR WIENER
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH US IN THIS
BILL TO YOU AND YOUR COMMITTEE
AFTER HEARING TODAY COLLEAGUES
SB TWO SIXTY A IS LEGISLATION
TO ENSURE THAT VOTERS ARE
RECEIVING ACCURATE INFORMATION.
IT WHEN THEY'RE VOTING FOR
BONDS ARE PARCEL TAXES THAT
THEY'RE NOT BEING MISLED AND
DIE OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
CITIES COUNTY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE ABLE TO CRAFTS SEVENTY FIVE
WORD BALLOT QUESTIONS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY COMPREHENSIBLE.
UNFORTUNATELY IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
AND. TWENTY SEVENTEEN THIS
LEGISLATURE. PAST AND THAT SORT
OF ONE UNDER THE RADAR FRANKLY
TWO PIECES OF LEGISLATION. DIE
REQUIRED THAT IN THE SEVENTY
FIVE WORD BALLOT QUESTION FOR
PARCEL TAXES IN BONDS. THE
REQUIRED A VOTERS BE INFORMED
ABOUT QUOTE UNQUOTE WHAT THEY
WILL HAVE TO PACK. AT ON THE
SURFACE THAT MAKES ALL THE
SENSE IN THE WORLD AND I VOTED
FOR THE ONE IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
BUT THERE WERE. SIGNIFICANT
UNFORESEEN CONSEQUENCES OF THIS
CHANGE BECAUSE SOMETHING THAT
SEEMS SO SIMPLE. IS NOT. I AM
THERE TO SIGNIFICANT
CONSEQUENCES FIRST. IF YOU ARE
TRYING TO PASS A TIERED PARCEL
TAX. WHERE SENIORS GOT AN
EXEMPTION WERE OUTSIDE PAYS
LESS. WORK COMMERCIAL PAYS MORE
THAN RESIDENTIAL FOR EXAMPLE.
IT IS LITERALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
FIT ALL OF THAT INFORMATION
INTO SEVENTY FIVE WORDS.AND
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT UNDER
THE STATE OF THE LAW RIGHT NOW.
TIERED PARCELTAXES PROGRESSIVE
PARCEL TAXES ARE BANNED
EFFECTIVELY. BECAUSE YOU CANNOT
FIT IN THE SEVENTY FIVE WORDS
THAT MEANS ALL PARCEL TAXES
WILL HAVE TO BE A ONE FLAT RATE
REGRESSIVE EVERYONE PAYS THE
SAME PARCEL TAX THAT IS NOT
FAIR IT'S NOT GOOD POLICY IN
ADDITION FOR BONDS ALL RIGHT
BECAUSE AT THE TIME THE VOTERSVOTE YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
TERMS OF THE BOND ISSUE ARE
GOING TO BE WHAT THE INTEREST
RATE IS GOING TO BE. ARE YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO PAY AND SO WE'RE
FORCING OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO SPECULATE. AND GIVE AN
ESTIMATE OR RANGE WHICH MAY BE
INACCURATE AND MISLEADING
PEOPLE ABOUT WHAT THEY WILL
ACTUALLY BE PAYING. ON THE
BOND. SO WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING
HERE IT INTO SB TWO SIXTY EIGHT
ONLY A BROAD COALITION OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND LABOR AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING GROUPS
BEHIND THIS MEASURE. IS NOT TO
REPEAL BUT TO MOVE THIS
INFORMATION INTO THE VOTER
GUIDE. AND TO REQUIRE. FOR THE
FIRST TIME A PARENTHETICAL IN
THE SEVENTY FIVE WORK QUESTION
THAT SAYS SEE VOTER GUIDE FOR
TAX RATE INFORMATION WE WORKED
OUT THAT LANGUAGE IN ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS. IT SAYS THE WORD TAX
IT SAYS THAT THERE WERE YOU
WANT TO SEE YOUR TAX RATE
INFORMATION. GO TO THE VOTER
GUIDE AND WE THINK THAT THE
STRIKES A GOOD BALANCE IN TREND
HAVING TRANSPARENCY NOT
MISLEADING VOTERS NOT BANNING
PROGRESSIVE TIERED PARCEL
TAXES. AND HAVING INFORMATION
THAT THE VOTERS. NEED. WE DO
HAVE TODAY SOMEONE WOULD PLEASE.
ALL THAT UP BRADY. AN EXAMPLE
OF THE TO YOUR PARCEL TAX THAT
IS NO LONGER LEGAL IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THIS IS COMES
FROM ACTUAL PARCEL TAXES IN
EXISTENCE. DIFFERENT TYPES OF
LAND PAY DIFFERENT AMOUNTS. I'M
THE WHERE IT GRAY'S AL IS A
SEVENTY FIVE WORDS. SO IT'S NOT
EVEN CLOSE YOU JUST CAN'T FIT
IT IN THERE AND WHO ON EARTH
WOULD WANT TO VOTER. TO HAVE A
BALLOT QUESTION LIKE THAT
ANYWAY. I BUT REGARDLESS YOU
CAN'T DO IT AND SO THIS HAS A
VERY REAL WORLD IMPACT ON OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. I WITH ME
TODAY TESTIFYING OR REBEKAH.
PURELY FROM THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE SCHOOL HOUSING AND
JEFF NEAL FROM COALITION FOR US
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS REBEKAH CURLY ON BEHALF
OF THE COALITION PRODUCT WITH
SCHOOL HOUSING REPRESENTING
SCHOOL DISTRICT SOME FACILITIES
ISSUES IN SUPPORT LOCAL BONDS
ARE THE PRIMARY SOURCE OF
REVENUE TO REPAIR CONSTRUCT
BUILD UP GRADE SCHOOL
FACILITIES. IT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE COMMUNICATE
TAX IMPACTS CLEARLY AND
ACCURATELY TO OUR COMMUNITIES
IN ORDER TO MEAN TRUST AS THE
SENATOR DESCRIBED RECENT
CHANGES TO THE ELECTIONS CODE
ARE MAKING IT SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE DIFFICULT FOR SCHOOLS.
ESPECIALLY LOW WELL DISTRICTS
TO MEET THE OBLIGATIONS TO
HOUSE ALL STUDENTS I'M AND IT
IS PREVENTING SCHOOLS FROM
BEING ABLE TO FORWARD WITH
PLACING BONDS ON THEIR LOCAL
BALLOTS. OUT AS THE SENATOR
DESCRIBED FOR BONDS THE RATES
DO CHANGE AND ONE EXAMPLE THAT
WE LOOKED AT. IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE IT WAS NINETEEN
DOLLARS PER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ASSESSED
VALUATION THE NEXT YEAR THAT
I'M OUT WHEN UP TO SIXTY FOUR
DOLLARS PER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ASSESSED
VALUATION WHEN THE GREAT
RECESSION HIT. THE VALUES TANK
YOU CAN SEE THAT'S A PRETTY BIG
SPREAD. THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT
THIS INFORMATION DOES NOT MAKE
SENSE FOR LOCAL BONDS WE DON'T
HAVE THE SPACE ON THE SEVENTY
FIVE WORD BALLOT LABEL TO MAKE
A DETAILED EXPLANATION OF UP TO
VOTERS AND THE RESULT IS VOTER
CONFUSION. POLLING DOES SHOW
THAT SUPPORT THOSE BACK UP FOR
THESE MEASURES ONCE VOTERS GET
A DETAILED EXPLANATION OF THE
TAX IMPLICATIONS FOR THEM IN
THEIR PERSONAL SITUATION WE
JUST DON'T HAVE THE SPACE TO DO
THAT ON THE BALLOT LABEL. WE DO
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION ON THE
TAX RATE STATEMENT IN THE VOTER
GUIDE AND I SPEAK TO SIXTY
EIGHT IN HAPPENS BUT IT MISSION
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL I'M
DOCTOR SUCH AS WHY THE RATES
MAY CHANGE. FOR THESE REASONS
WE BELIEVE THAT SB TWO SIX GAVE
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
TRANSPARENCY AND HOPES. VOTERS
REALLY UNDERSTAND IMPACTS OF
MEASURES THANK YOU. MORNING MR
CHAIR MEMBERS JEFF KNEW WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION A CAT. WE SUPPORT
SB TWO SIXTY EIGHT FOR ALL THE
REASONS STATED TO CORRECT THESE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF THE
RECENT CHANGES. IN ADDITION TO
NEW TO YOUR GREAT TAXES. I ALSO
WANT TO BRING TO YOUR ATTENTION
THAT EXISTING TIERED RATE TAXES
THAT COMMUNITIES HAVE ALREADY
VOTED FOR. WITH THE
OVERWHELMING NUMBERS THAT WE
REQUIRE FOR LOCAL TAXES I
CANNOT BE RENEWED BECAUSE THEY
DO HAVE THESE MULTIPLE TIERS
PERHAPS THEY EXEMPT VETERANS
ARE THEY EXEMPTS. LOW INCOME
SENIORS OR THEY- UNIMPROVED
AGRICULTURAL LAND IN DIFFERENT
RATE THAN IMPROVED LAND. A AND
ALSO LOCAL BONDS THAT ARE
SECURED BY A TWO YEAR BREAK
TAXES THESE ARE THE BONDS THAT
WE USED TO BUILD FIRE STATIONS.
OF FLOOD CONTROL PROJECTS. THE
COUNTY CITIES AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS AS WELL AS SCHOOLS I
USE THESE BONDS ALL. IMPORTANT
INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE WE
PROVIDE AND SO THE SOLUTION AS
SENATOR WIENER INDICATE IS NOT
TO ROLL BACK THE REQUIREMENT
BUT I'M BACK TO PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION TO VOTERS AND TO
PROVIDE IT YEAH WITH LANGUAGE
THAT THEY ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND.
INSTEAD OF THE CURRENT
REQUIREMENT WHICH WHICH AS THAT
MY COLLEAGUE SAID VOTERS POLINA
SHOWN VOTERS FIND CONFUSING
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND IT. SO WE
APPRECIATE CENTER. WINNER BRING
IN THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
FORWARD AND JUROR I'VE OF.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
BUT YOU'RE MEMBERS DON'T GIVENS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICT ASSOCIATION ALSO
SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
KAREN L<c.cyan>G ON BEHALF OF</c>
MARYLAND AND BREED IN THE CITY
AND COUNTY TERMS IS GONE
SUPPORT. MORNING MR CARE
MEMBERS JEAN HEARST HERE TODAY
WE HAVE. BEEN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
DISTRICTS. IN THE SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SUPPORT. YOUR THIS FEATURE
MEMBERS BOARD ROOM WITH SANTA
CLARA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN
STRONG SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
UNDERESTIMATE US ON BEHALF OFTHE MAYOR OF OAKLAND AND THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THE MORNING SALINA
PRIOR CALIFORNIA HAWAII STATE
CONFERENCE OF INDEFINITELY
SEEKING SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CRISTINA ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THIS IS A SPORT OPPOSITION.
REMEMBER OLD LOW OBERNOLTE.
SENATOR WIENER ONCE YOU CAN
OVER ONE OF THEIR MIND. YEAH
THERE ARE YOU GOING TO HEAR
YEAH. IF YOU LIKE THEN WIENER
WITH IT YOU WANT TO JUST COME
SO THAT THE END OF THE DIET ALL
RIGHT. OKAY BUT WE ARE WORKED
OUT I'M SORRY. MY PHONE. YOU
TO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND I KNOW IT'S A
LITTLE UNUSUAL FOR ME TO BE
TESTIFYINGIN OPPOSITION HERE
BUT THIS IS AN ISSUE I'M VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT. THE SECTION
OF THE STATE CODE THAT I'VE
BEEN WORKING IN FIVE YEARS IN
FACT. BOTH OF THE PIECES OF
LEGISLATION THAT THIS THE
AUTHOR REFERENCE WERE MY BILLS
SO HE IS SEEKING TO EXEMPT.
THESE TYPES OF BOND ISSUANCES
FROM THE GARMENTS THAT WE
CREATED COLLECTIVELY IN THE
LEGISLATURE. FOUR YEARS AGO.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL IS
NOT THAT THERE AREN'T PROBLEMS
THAT NEED TO BE SOLVED WITH THE
LANGUAGE FOR THESE BONDS. ARE
ONE AB ONE NINETY FIVE PASSED
TWO YEARS AGO IT WAS
IMMEDIATELY CLEAR. THAT SOME
SITUATIONS HAD NOT BEEN
ADEQUATELY THOUGHT OUT FOR
EXAMPLE. WHAT SHOULD BE DONE
WHEN. A TEAR TAXES IMPOSED WHAT
SHOULD BE DONE WHEN THE
INTEREST RATE OR THE DURATION
OF A BOND IS NOT KNOWN. WHEN
THE ISSUE WAS PLACED ON THE
BALLOT. HOWEVER COLLEAGUES FOR
THE LAST TWO YEARS I HAVE
AUTHORED LEGISLATION EACH YEAR
TO ATTEMPT TO FIX THOSE
PROBLEMS AND WHAT IS BECOME
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR. IS THAT THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL ARE NOT
INTERESTED. IN MERELY FIXING
THE PROBLEM AND CONDENSING THE
LANGUAGE ON THE BALLOT
STATEMENT WHAT THEY REALLY WANT
TO DO. IS TO AVOID HAVING TO
TELL THE VOTERS THAT THEY'RE
VOTING ON A TAX INCREASE. AND
IF YOU WANT PROOF OF THAT. I
HAVE HERE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
THEY'VE BEEN DRAFTED BY LEDGE
COUNCIL WHAT THEY DO IS THEY
SAY THEY COMPLETELY AGREE WITH
THE SENATOR. THEY SAY LET'S
MOVE ALL OF THE LANGUAGE ABOUT
THE RATE INFORMATION ON TO. THE
VOTER INFORMATION GUIDE WHERE
THERE'S PLENTY OF ROOM. TO
LISTED AND INSTEAD LET'S JUST
SAY THISLET'S SAY. THIS
MEASURE INCREASES PROPERTY
TAXES. SEE VOTER GUIDE. DOESN'T
TAKE UP MUCH SPACE ALL IT DOES
IS MAKE IT CLEAR. THAT VOTING
ON THIS MEASURE WILL INCREASE
PROPERTY TAXES IF INDEED THAT
IS THE CASE THAT IS NOT
CONFUSING. THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
TRUE AND I THINK IT ENCOMPASSES
THE PURPOSES OF THE BILL'S
SPONSOR HOWEVER WE OFFER THESE
AMENDMENTS IN. THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE AND THEY
WERE SUMMARILY REJECTED BY THE
BILL'S SPONSOR. I THINK THAT
THAT PROVES WHAT THE ACTUAL
INTENT IS. UP. THE OTHER THING
I'D LIKE TO SAY HERE IS THAT
THIS MEASURE. IS A COMPLETELY
UNNECESSARY BECAUSE IF THE
PROPONENTS OF THE BILL BELIEVE
VOTERS ARE CONFUSED. THEN IT WE
SHOULD HAVE LOTS OF THESE BOND
MEASURES THAT ARE BEING PLACED
ON THE BALLOT AND FAILING. AND
THAT IS NOT THE CASE I LOOKED
AT ALL OF THE BOND MEASURES
STATEWIDE THAT WERE PROPOSED IN
THE LAST TWO YEAR ELECTION
CYCLE. AND YOU KNOW THE PASSAGE
RATE WAS ALL OF THEM COMPLIED
WITH AB ONE NINETY FIVE. THE
PASSAGE RATE WAS OVER 82% SO
IT'S CLEAR TO ME THAT VOTERS
ARE NOT CONFUSED BY THESE
EXTINCT EXISTING LANGUAGE. SO
OUR I HAVE GIVEN THE SERGEANT
ARMS A LITTLE HAND OUT TO PASS
OUT TO YOU. THIS BILL WAS A
LAST MINUTE GOT AMEND A HOWEVER
IN THE LAST MONTH AND A HALF
SINCE THE BILL HAS BEEN IN
PRINT. WE HAVE HAD EDITORIAL
BOARDS OF NEWSPAPERS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHERE HE
AND ON THIS BILL. AND THE
FEEDBACK HAS NOT BEEN KIND. AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. FROM ALL
DIFFERENT POLITICAL STRIPES
BIG. OUTLETS LIKE LOS ANGELES
TIMES SERVICES WE CANNOT
CHRONICLE SAN DIEGO UNION
TRIBUNE. THE US SACRAMENTO BEE
AND THEY'RE USING WORDS LIKE.
SNEAKY DISHONEST DESPICABLE. A
AND ALSO LIKE TO CALL ATTENTION
TO MY FAVORITE PART OF THE BILL
WHICH I HAVE NOT A LOT OF
ATTENTION ACTUALLY THERE'S ONLY
ONE OF THE EDITORIALS THERE THE
MENTIONS IT BUT IT'S ANOTHER
CHANGE THAT THE BILL WOULD BEG
TO THE LANGUAGE OF AB ONE
NINETY FIVE SAYS THIS FAILURE
TO COMPLY WITH THIS CHAPTER
SHALL NOT AFFECT THE VALIDITY
OF EITHER OF THE FOLLOWING A
BOND ISSUE FELLING THE SALE AND
DELIVERY OF A BONDS OR A TAX
FOLLOWING ITS INITIAL
IMPOSITION SO BASICALLY WHAT
THAT MEANS IS WE'RE GOING TO
CHANGE THE RULES THERE STILL BE
RIPPLES. BUT WE'RE GOING TO
GIVE ANYONE WITH A MEASURE ON
THE FAT FREE PASS IF THEY DON'T
FOLLOW THE RULES THE ACTION
THAT THEY TOOK IS STILL VALID
AND I WOULD SAY THAT THAT IS
COMPLETELY WRONG SO I WOULD ASK
YOU COLLEAGUES IF YOU WOULD
VOTE NO ON THIS OR AT THE VERY
LEAST I THINK THAT THIS NEEDS
TO BE A TO YOUR BILL I DON'T
THINK IT SHOULD BE A LAST
MINUTE GOT DEMAND THAT HERE
WERE CONSIDERING THE DAY BEFORE
THE END OF SESSION I THINK WE
NEED TO HAVE A REASON
THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION ABOUT
THIS BECAUSE IT IS GOING TO
SUCH AN- ON A TRIP. BALLOT
LEAPING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. CONSIDERING USE. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COME MORNING
DAVID WILL FOR THE HOWARD
JARVIS TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION
WE'RE OPPOSED TO SB TWO SIXTY
EIGHT TODAY MEMBERS IT'S WORTH
NOTING WE WERE THE SPONSORS OF
A SOME WOMEN OBERNOLTE IS TWO
BILLS AT THAT HE REFERENCE
DURING HIS TESTIMONY AND
MEMBERS WHAT'S FRUSTRATING
ABOUT THE BILL BEFORE US IS
THAT WE TRIED TO DO THE RIGHT
THING WE KNEW FULL WELL THAT
LOCAL BONDS EVEN AS THE SENATOR
MENTIONED WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
HARD TIME COMPLYING WITH THE
BALLOT LANGUAGE REQUIREMENT AB
ONE NINETY FIVE WE- FOR THREE
YEARS TO FIND LANGUAGE. TO
EXEMPT THAT. AND TAKE CARE OF
IT. ALSO AND I MEAN I PRESENTED
LANGUAGE TO THE AUTHOR EVEN AS
EARLY AS THE LAST MONTH TO THE
AUTHOR STAFF. TO SAY. TO USE
EVEN THE PHRASE MAY INCREASE
YOUR PROPERTY TAXES BECAUSE THE
AUTHOR IS RIGHT IN HIS
PRESENTATION. WHEN BONDS ARE
PASSED NOT EVERY YEAR PROPERTY
TAXES GO UP AS A RESULT THE
BONDS BONDS ARE SOLD IN CYCLES.
AND AT DIFFERENT RATES AND
ROUTINE SO IT'S NOT A GUARANTEE
THAT PROPERTY TAXES WILL GO UP
YEAR OVER YEAR AS A RESULT OF
FUN SO WE DID BECAUSE THE
MOMENT THAT SAY. IT MAY
INCREASE YOUR PROPERTY TAXES TO
THE AUTHOR STAFF AND THAT WAS
SUMMARILY REJECTED AND NOT
HEARD SO I MEAN WE'VE- SPENT
YEARS AND YEARS TRYING TO BEND
OVER BACKWARDS. TO ACCOMMODATE.
THIS PROPOSAL THE CHANGES THAT
NEEDED TO BE MADE AGAIN OUT OF
A DESIRE TO GIVE VOTERS
ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY. AND
UNFORTUNATELY THE BILL BEFORE
US GOES FAR BEYOND THE
NECESSARY FIX. AND YOU KNOW WE
WOULD ARGUE REPRESENTS ABROAD
OVER A PRIOR OVERREACH.
TRANSPARENCIES DIMINISHED AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE NOT HELD
TO ACCOUNT IF SPECIAL TAXES ARE
REMOVED FROM THE BALLOT LABEL.
VOTERS DESERVE BETTER. AND I
JUST HEARD BACK TO. WHAT SOME
WOMEN MENTIONED IN HIS
TESTIMONY. IS THE BILL EVEN
NOW. 82% OF ALL BOND TAXES
PASSED IN LOCAL ELECTIONS IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. I'M WITH THEM
FROM WESTERN ABOUT. IS IT
NECESSARY THANKS. TO REDO IT.
UNLIKE CUSHION I CAN DRAW IS
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO SKIRT
TRANSPARENT YET ASK FOR AN OF A.
WELL I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
WITH THIS BILL IT IS A MAJOR.
RE WRITE IF YOU WILL OF
LEGISLATION THAT DID PASS. AND
AT THE LEAST SUCH CHANGES.
OUGHT NOT BE OCCURRING AT THE
LAST MINUTE. AND THERE OUGHT TO
BE PLENTY OF OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE CITIZENS. OF CALIFORNIANS
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON SO OFTEN
THAT DOES NOT HAPPEN AROUND
HERE. AND I THINK THAT'S
HAPPENING IN THIS PARTICULAR
BILL HERE AND IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT SOME OF THE PEOPLE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ARE AFRAID. OF
THE CITIZENS HAVING FULL.
AMOUNT OF INFORMATION AND I
SPEAK IS THE LONG TIME CHAMPION
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT AROUND HERE.
BUT THEY LIKE TO BE INSULATED
WE'VE GOT ANOTHER BILL THAT
JUST WAS UP YESTERDAY THAT
ALLOWS THE LOCAL ENTITY TO IN
FACT TECH IT'S VOTERS. TO CRAFT
THE LINES OF THE VOTE. UNDER
PROPOSITION. TO THE VANTAGE OF
PASSING THAT PROPOSITION IN
THEIR COMMUNITY IT'S RATHER
TAXING. A COUPLE COUNTIES WHEN
I REPRESENT AND WHEN I USED TO
REPRESENT. THAT'S VOTER
SHOPPING. I DON'T THINK THAT'S
WHERE WE OUGHT TO DO BUSINESS
THIS BILL DESERVES A LOT MORE
SCRUTINY A LOT MORE TIME. I
CANNOT SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NIELSEN HERTZBERG. WHY IS ALL
THESE NEWSPAPERS JUST BRUTALIZE
THIS DEAL THESE ARE DUMB PEOPLE
WHAT WHAT'S I MEAN I GO THROUGH
EACH ONE OF THESE THINGS AND
MORE PORTANTINO WHEN A
PARTICULAR AGE IT IS ALL OF IN
THE BOTTOM ONE ABOUT REDLANDS
DAILY FACTS. MY FAVORITE
NEWSPAPER. YEAH SO HEY I'M A
REDLANDS GRADUATE GUYS COME ON
THE PUBLISHED ALL MY STUFF. BUT
FAILURE TO COMPLY WAS CHAPTERS
FROM ANOTHER STILL INTERNET SO
I APOLOGIZE IF I'M WRONG. THE
VALIDITY OF ANY BOND ISSUES
FOLLOWING THE SALE AND DELIVERY
OF BONTA BASE LET'S LOCAL
OFFICIALS OFF ENTIRELY OFF THE
HOOK. SO IN A NUTSHELL BUT WHAT
WHY ARE ALL THESE EDITORIAL
BOARDS. DUMBER BOX RIGHT SO US
CENTER THANK YOU FIRST OF ALL
THAT THE VALIDITY LANGUAGE JUST
MAD RED IS EXISTING LAW. WELL
THAT'S NOT WE'RE NOT CHANGING
THAT OKAY AND I THINK IT'S
UNFORTUNATE IS IN A LOT OF TAX
EXAGGERATION SWIRLING ABOUT
THIS BILL I ALSO AND I DON'T
HAVE THE EDITORIAL. LIST THAT.
YOU HAVE I WANT TO BE VERY VERY
CLEAR ABOUT THAT THAT'S FINE.
THAT VOTE YOU KNOW AND I IT
MIGHT MY COLLEAGUE HERE IS MY
FRIEND WE WORKED ON BILLS
TOGETHER A LOT OF RESPECT FROM
HAS BEEN VERY. EFFECTIVELY
READING FROM THESE UP AS HE DID
IT VERY EFFECTIVELY ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. OF WHERE WE HAD
YOU KNOW LITTLE NICE TO BE. ON
THE BULK OF THOSE EDITORIALS
ARE NOT FROM EDITORIAL BOARDS
THEY ARE OUTSIDE GUESTS
OPINIONS FROM PEOPLE LIKE. YOU
KNOW DOWN WALTERS AND OTHERS
WHO LIKE TO TAKE SHOTS. SOME OF
THEM ARE YOU KNOW BECAUSE OF
THE CONSOLIDATION AND MEDIA IT
GETS PUBLISHED IN ONE. AND ALL
THE SUDDEN IT'S PUBLISHED IN
TEN AND IT LOOKS LIKE TEN
DIFFERENT EDITORIAL WORK WHERE
IT'S REALLY ONE. ON THE ONE THE
SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE TO MY
KNOWLEDGE HAS NEVER THAT A
TWELVE WAS NEVER EDITORIALIZED
ABOUT THIS. THE LA TIMES DID
AND WITH ALL RESPECT TO THE LA
TIMES OF A LOT OF RESPECT FOR
THAT IT'S REAL BOARD. THAT
EDITORIAL COMPLETELY IGNORED
THE ACTUAL REASONS FOR THIS
NEVER ACKNOWLEDGE THAT YOUR
PARCEL TAXES ARE BANNED. UNDER
THESE EXISTING LAWS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO REFORM. AND THEN AT
THE END OF THE LA TIMES
EDITORIAL BOARD. ACTUALLY SAID
WELL MAYBE YOU CAN DO WITH THE
WAY YOU'RE DOING IT TO CHANGE
THE LANGUAGE A LITTLE BIT. AND
THAT GETS INTO ANOTHER ISSUE I
REALLY I'M VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
MY- COLLEAGUE FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WHO I THINK IS A LOT OF
INTEGRITY. AND OUR JARVIS ALSO
HAVING KNOWLEDGE. THAT THESE
LAWS. ARE VERY PROBLEMATIC. AND
MISTER OBERNOLTE HAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND HERE AGAIN TODAY
AND HOWARD JARVIS SAID. OKAY
FINE. MOVE EVERYTHING INTO THE
BALLOT HOW BOOK WHICH IS THE
CORE OF WHAT WE'RE DOING. WHAT
WE WANTED THE PARENTHETICAL TO
BE DIFFERENT WE WANT TO SAY. AN
IN SAM LEAVE THE ADVOCATED FOR
QUOTE THIS WILL RAISE. TAXES
WHICH OF COURSE PAUL FOR THE
40% OF CALPERS INTO A RENTERS
YOU DON'T PAY PROPERTY TAXES.
AND ALSO FALLS IF YOU HAVE A
PRO A PARCEL TAX THAT YOU WERE
SIMPLY EXTENDING AT THIS RATE
IT'S NOT RAISE YOUR TAXES. AND
SO NOW THEY'RE SAYING. THIS MAY
RAISE TAXES. I. FIRST US IN IT
AND IT WAS I THINK HE- TRIED TO
STRIKE A BALANCE TO CHANGE IT
TO. THE VOTER GUIDE FOR TAX
RATE INFORMATION TO USE THE
WORD TAX THE SAID THERE IS A
TAX RATE AT ISSUE HERE. SENDS A
CLEAR SIGNAL SO NO ONE WILL BE
BELIEVE THAT THEY'RE VOTING FOR
SOMETHING OTHER THAN A TAX. AND
I THINK IT WAS A GOOD BALANCE
IN THE END. THIS YEAR THE
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE OF NOT
REQUIRING ALL THIS INFORMATION
AND SEVEN FIVE WORDS. THAT THAT
WAS IN PLACE FOR A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE YEARS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IT'S ONLY FOR A COUPLE
YEARS. BY CHANGING SOME
LONGSTANDING LAW WHICH IS GOING
BACK MOST OF THE WAY TO THE WAY
IT ALWAYS WAS IN CALIFORNIA.
OTHER QUESTIONS. THE BILL SIX
CENTER HERTZBERG MOVES THE BILL
PROJECT CLOSE. I RESPECT WITH
RIVAL THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
ANSWER TO THE CALL THE ROLL
MOTION IS ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
BE CONFERRED IN NUMBER HI I'M
BURKE AYE NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE LEYVA
LEYVA AYE STERN. STERN I. THANK
YOU FELT LIKE YOU IS. ON.
LOOKING FOR THE OFFICE. YEAH
OPEN THE ROLE ON SB SIX NINE
SIX PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS HERTZBERG HI HERTZBERG
HI OKAY ALL RIGHT THAT
CONCLUDES THE HEARING TODAY
WE'LL SEE YOU ALL. JANUARY